WHY DOES THIS PICTURE HAVE
TO BE BLURRED WHEN I CAN
SHOW THIS PIK I POSTED ON
INSTAGRAM FULL NIPPLE.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING HERE.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
IT WAS A PHASE.
ALL RIGHT.
I WENT THROUGH WHAT I CALLED
THE MELLON BALLING PHASE,
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
BUT IT RAISES A QUESTION OF
WHY IS THE NIPPLE THE LINE
OF DEMARCATION FOR A WOMAN
TO PUT A PICTURE ONLINE
IS IT BECAUSE IT'S THE MOST
FUNCTIONAL PART?
IS THIS WHY, IS THIS WHY
IT'S OKAY TO SHOW MEN'S
NIPPLES BECAUSE THEY SERVE
NO PURPOSE?
MAYBE THIS IS WHY CARS HAVE
ENGINES UNDER HOODS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY, BUT IT
SEAMS LIKE AMERICANS ARE
AFRAID OF FUNCTIONALITY.
SO WHILE WE'S AT IT LET'S BLUR
OUT EYE, NOSE, MOUTH,
ANYTHING THAT'S FUNCTIONAL.
BY THE WAY, I WANT TO SAY
NIPPLES ARE NOT THE
ENEMY IN THE WORLD, PEOPLE!
THEY'RE JUST NOT!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
ALL RIGHT.
ISIS IS THE ENEMY.
THEY'RE USING CHILDREN TO
[BLEEP] MURDER PEOPLE.
THEY'RE A MUCH BIGGER THINGS
GOING ON IN THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
BY THE WAY, WE'RE A JOKE TO,
BECAUSE WE SPEND VALUABLE LEGAL
PROCESS AND MENTAL ENERGY TRYING
TO PUT HUMAN PUPILLA IN
WITNESS PROTECTION.
SO GUESS WHAT.
WE'RE TO THE GOING TO
FORGET ABOUT TITS.
I STILL NOTICE THEM.
PEOPLE STILL NOTICE THEM.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
THEM.
(APPLAUSE)
SHOWING TITS IS NOT
PORNOGRAPHIC.
SHOWING SOMETHING JIZZING ON
TO YOUR TITS IS PORNOGRAPHIC.
AND BY THE WAY, ARE
WE-- WOMEN WANT TO PUT THEIR
BOOB'S ON THE INTERNET AND
WE'RE FIGHTING THAT?
WT-[BLEEP], THIS IS A GOLDEN
AGE!
DO YOU KNOW-- LISTEN.
WHEN I WAS A KID IF YOU WANTED
TO SEE TITS ON THE INTERNET,
YOU HAD TO MAKE THEM OUT  OF
COMMAS. LIKE, THERE WAS NO WAY
TO DO IT OTHERWISE.
WHAT AM I SUPPOSED TO TELL
MY KIDS IF THEY SEE MILEY'S
BOOBIES.
WELL HERE'S WHAT:
FIRST OFF, STOP USING YOUR
MOUTH TO BREATHE THROUGH AND
SHOVE HOT WINGS IN, AND USE
IT TO HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT
HEALTHY SEXUALITY WITH THEM.
HEY, KIDS, MOMMIES HAVE MAMMARY
GLANDS THAT ARE DIFFERENT FROM
DADDIES. THEY ARE BEAUTIFUL
AND A PART OF NATURE AND
UNLIKE DADDIES SAND DOLLAR-Y
SCAREOLAS, THEY ACTUALLY SERVE A
PURPOSE THAT HELPS FOSTER LIFE.
THEN YOU TELL YOUR KIDS YOU
LOVE THEM, TUCK THEM IN BED
AND YOU GROW THE [BLEEP] UP
AND TRY TO ESTABLISH
SIGNIFICANCE SOME OTHER WAY
THAN STIRRING UP POINTLESS
BULL [BLEEP].
I AM SO MAD.  THIS IS SO STUPID
I'M SO MAD!
THIS IS SO STUPID.
ALSO, I HAVE BEEN TALKING
WAY TOO LONG.
BUT I ALSO FEEL SORRY FOR
YOU BECAUSE SOME ASSHOLE
HADN'T MADE YOU ASHAMED OF
YOUR BODY YOU WOULDN'T TEACH
YOUR CHILDREN THEY SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF THEIRS.
SO, NOW I WANT TO PROTEST, ALL
RIGHT.
SO COMEDIANS WHAT ARE SOME
THINGS THAT WE CAN DO TO
PROTEST NIPPLE CENSORSHIP.
ROB RIGGLE, GO.
>> A MILLION NIPPLE MARCH.
>> CHRIS: YEAH.
PERFECT.
>> PREFERABLY IN FEBRUARY.
>> CHRIS: YEAH, FEBRUARY.
TO REALLY MAKE IT STAND OUT.
NICK SWARDSON.
>> I'M HUNG LIKE A NIPPLE SO
BLUR MY DICK PICS.
>> CHRIS: OKAY.
I THINK THEY WERE ALREADY DOING
THAT.
>> I LIKE THAT.
>> CHRIS: ARI SHAFFIR.
>> FIRST OF ALL, CAI STOP AND
SAY THAT THAT WAS AN AWESOME
RANT FOR BOOB'S.
>> CHRIS: OH, THANKS. NO,
CONTINUE.
>> I'VE GOT ONE THAT'S LIKE
MOVEMBER, BUT IT'S FEBRUARYOLA.
>> CHRIS: YEAH, OKAY. PERFECT.
AND RIGHT NOW IT'S TIME TO